us
when it comes to voting on civil rights
legislation
while the filibuster's not mentioned a
single time in the constitution it is
true
eruption
thank you mr president i ask unanimous
consent that the closure vote on the
motion to concur be at 8 pm without
object is there objection without
objection thank you i appreciate the
courtesy of my colleague senator from
new mexico we had no choice but to do it
at 6 30.
so
the importance of us being here today
go goes right in the face of having this
conver conversation have debate i
appreciate my republican colleagues
who've come to the floor to engage in
some debate and some colloquy
i like senator kane
came to the senate bit naive
i thought i'd debate half of dear all
the time
i came here thinking that i could offer
an amendment at any time
that i could offer a unanimous consent
at any time
it's not the case
this is not the senate that
our founders
envisioned
now
if you feel moved to oppose a piece of
legislation
if you're passionate about an issue you
should have the courage to come to the
senate floor in front of your colleagues
and the american people
you should not be allowed to phone it in
from behind closed doors
this chamber has changed
just as the times have changed
so it's the responsibility of every one
of us to make sure that the senate works
better
not for us but for the american people
now in closing in 1805 vice president
aaron burr suggested that the senate
removed from its rules the previous
question motion
which allowed the chamber simple
majority to end debate on a bill
he viewed the rule as completely
unnecessary and urged the senate to
clean up its rule book because after
everyone spoke and debated they'd vote
a year later the senate removed the
previous question motion
leaving a loophole that allowed the
minority to take advantage and use what
we now know as the filibuster
unfortunately burr could not foresee the
obstructionism of decades to come
in the following decades pro-slavery
senators co-opted the filibuster to
protect the interests of white southern
enslavers men such as john calhoun
abused the filibuster to obstruct civil
rights efforts
and according to historians between 1917
and 1994
30 measures favored by the sitting
president simple majorities in the house
and senate half of which addressed civil
rights
they all died
thanks to the filibuster
the same procedural tool proved to be
even more useful
to southern senators who sought to block
civil rights legislation
including anti-lynching bills
not until 64 did the senate successfully
overcome a filibuster
to pass important civil rights
legislation and subsequent voting rights
legislation
now history should act as a teacher to
all of us that history will remind us
who voted today on the side
of the people
i'm proud that this effort includes my
native american voting rights act
which will ensure tribes and native
americans and alaska natives and voters
on tribal lands will have equal access
to the electoral process
access to the ballot box is the
cornerstone of our democratic system and
without equitable access to it we cannot
stand on the world stage
and claim that we are all leaders in the
fight for liberty
and justice for all
now my republican colleagues have proven
time and again that they are not
interested in acting on this issue
washington republicans have made the
political calculation that they have a
partisan advantage here
they are too comfortable shrugging their
shoulders
and sitting on the sidelines while
states chip away at the right to vote
i know where i stand mr president
all we are asking for today is the
opportunity to vote on this critical
piece of legislation
after everyone here has said their peace
i urge my colleagues to do the right
thing today
to do right by our democracy
and to send the freedom to vote
john r lewis act
to the president's desk
i thank you all and i yield the floor
[Music]
[Music]
senator from nevada
thank you
our democracy is extraordinary because
it is built on the bedrock idea that
through free and fair elections the
citizens who make up this great country
well they have a voice
that each person's vote truly matters
that in america the people have the
power
but at this moment our democracy is
threatened
republican state legislatures and
governors all over the country are
writing laws designed to restrict the
right to vote
make it harder for tens of millions of
eligible citizens to cast their ballot
and silence
the american people's voice in the
process
make no mistake
this is an unprecedented coordinated
attack to make voting harder for
eligible citizens and make it easier for
bad actors to sabotage our future
elections
in my state of nevada
we've bucked that trend when it comes to
voting rights
we've strengthened the right to vote
providing easier access to the ballot
box for eligible voters while ensuring
fair elections
these measures that governor steve
sisolak signed into law include
establishing a permanent vote by mail
system
expanding the early voting period and
making it more convenient
to register and to vote
but while nevada has moved forward to
protect and strengthen voting rights we
are not immune from the attempts to
sabotage it
in nevada
the leading republican candidate for our
secretary of state stated that he would
have refused
i repeat would have refused
to certify president biden's victory in
our state
even though the results were certified
by a republican secretary of state and
unanimously upheld by the nevada supreme
court
that same candidate
opened the door to certifying alternate
alternate electors in future
presidential elections
in nevada
contrary
to the actual election results
and in nevada
leading republican candidates for
governor are promising to undo our
progress and make it harder for nevadans
to vote because they refuse to accept
the results of the 2020 election
they're pushing the former president's
false conspiracy theories that fueled
the january six insurrection
attacks like these they're a growing
threat to democracy
and exactly
exactly the reason we need to act
urgently
if we fail to do so we fail to do so
here and now new state laws will result
in hours long lines at the polls
overturned election results and masses
of disenfranchised voters
so let's talk about solutions
smart solutions
solutions that give every eligible voter
equal access to the ballot box
the freedom to vote act combined with
the john lewis voting right advancement
act
meets this moment it meets the moment
we are in with our democracy in crisis
it delivers real
meaningful action
first
this bill makes it easy for people to
register to vote
that does this by requiring states to
allow eligible americans to register
online and on election day
as well as update our automatic voter
registration system
this bill would also require states to
accurately maintain their voter
registration list and protect voters
against unwarranted purges from the
voter rolls
this way
those who should be eligible to vote can
do so without hassle
or
harassment
the freedom to vote act gives americans
more choices on when and how they can
legally vote through national standards
for early in-person voting
expanded mail-in voting
and finally
making election day
a national holiday
because
even if you're a hard-working american
who's busy working long hours looking
after your children caring for a sick
relative
you should still have access to the
ballot box
this bill would ensure election security
and prevent by prevent partisan sabotage
by requiring
post election audits and enhancing
enhancing protections for election
records
the freedom to vote act would also take
long needed steps to end political
corruption in our elections
it would accomplish this
by protecting us elections from foreign
interference
by prohibiting false information
designed to dissuade eligible voters
by promoting online
ad transparency
and
by putting an end
end to that dark money in our elections
to borrow a few words from the late
congressman john lewis
my former colleague from the house
a legendary civil rights leader an
american hero for whom this bill is
named
an inspiration
to us all and to
people all around the world
john lewis said and i quote
the right to vote
is the most powerful tool
in democracy
i'm going to repeat those words from
john lewis listen closely
the right to vote
is the most powerful
tool
in a
democracy each person's vote is their
voice
it's every citizen's opportunity to
weigh into what matters most to them for
their family for their community for
their country for the world it matters
it is fundamental to our democracy to
the very definition of what it means to
be an american citizen
for each and every one of us to stand up
to stand tall to get to the ballot box
be able to vote the way we choose and
have the assurance that our vote is
counted
it matters
each person matters
and so
if the senate cannot move forward on
this critically important legislation
under the status quo
and it is time to reform the rules to
restore the senate to pass this
legislation
because only then
can we protect our democracy's future
and secure the freedom to vote
for every eligible american
for this generation and for the
generations to come
thank you i yield back
senator from wyoming thank you mr
president i come to the floor today to
oppose the democrats federal election
takeover
the president just gave one of his rare
press
conferences it was only the second one
he actually gave on american soil
the white house seems to think that the
cure for joe biden's poll numbers is
more communications from joe biden
and the press conference went on for one
hour and 54 minutes
the white house doesn't have a
communications problem it has an agenda
problem
the american people understand exactly
what president biden and senator schumer
and speaker pelosi are trying to sell
the american people aren't buying it
democrats don't need a message reset
they need a better agenda for the nation
what we're about to vote on tonight has
nothing to do with the priorities of the
american people
has nothing to do with coronavirus
has nothing to do with 40-year high
inflation numbers which are biting into
the paychecks of the american people
it has nothing to do with the crisis at
the southern border where two million
illegal immigrants have crossed the
border this year
criminals among them drug smugglers
among them gang members among them
it's nothing to do with what's driven
the president's approval numbers to an
all-time low of 40 percent which it is
today
in the gallup poll
democrats number one goal they stated at
the beginning of the congress is to pass
a federal takeover of elections
an election takeover bill was the first
bill they introduced
democrats are ignoring what the american
people are demanding so that they can do
what their radical fringe is demanding
democrats want elections to be run by
washington d.c
instead of the 50 states
constitution is very clear it says the
states run our elections
why do they want to take over our
elections
well democrats want to do things like
banning voter id laws
now 80 percent of americans believe
people should have to show a photo id in
order to vote
senator schumer has already twice tried
to cram an election takeover bill down
the throat to the american public this
is the third time
so far
he has failed
so why
why has this continued to fail
not simply because republicans oppose it
it's failed because the american people
oppose it
the american people aren't looking for a
federal government takeover of elections
recent gallup poll asked people what
they think is the most important issue
facing our country
voting laws didn't crack the top twenty
in fact voting laws received less than
one percent of the vote it was an
asterisk
in the results
democrats scare tactics on voting laws
have utterly failed
now democrats are so desperate to change
our voting laws to their advantage that
they're going to try to break the senate
that's what they're doing now
the senate is supposed to be quote the
world's greatest deliberative body
some democrats want deliberations to end
forever
democrats claim they'll change our
election laws and then they'll stop
one time only
claim they'll only rig the game just
once
well we all know that's not true
they can't resist the temptation to rig
the u.s senate once they won't resist
the temptation to rig the rest of the
government either
once democrats change the rules we know
stopping them from doing everything
they've ever dreamed
pack the supreme court
add new states to the union
amnesty for illegal immigrants
try to take away the guaranteed rights
by the second amendment you name it
they could do it sooner or later they
will
this is a bill in the senate right now
to add four new justices to the supreme
court
46 democrats in the senate have signed
on to a bill for statehood for the
district of columbia
it's almost the entire democrat caucus
democrats have also introduced a bill to
give statehood to puerto rico
these bills become law democrats know
they'll get four more democrat senators
permanently
one
change to the senate rules
and america would have a permanent
one-party rule
don't take my word for it on amnesty
either just months ago democrats tried
to pass amnesty for 6.5 million illegal
immigrants
that's greater than the population of 32
of our 50 states
amnesty of this magnitude would
permanently remake our electorate
new york city has already granted the
right to vote to illegal immigrants
democrats break the rules of the senate
in order to change the rules
they'll pass amnesty as fast as they can
over the past year they have gone on
record they have sponsored the bills
yet they know that they have failed to
persuade the american public
to support this agenda
they know they'll never have bipartisan
support to pass the radical amnesty for
illegal immigrants
never have bipartisan support to ban
vote voter identification
never have bipartisan support for taxes
and punishing regulations that continue
to drive up the cost of energy
never persuade the american people to
support their radical extreme dangerous
and scary agenda
yet rather than change the agenda to
comply with what the american people
want the democrats want to change the
rules
so desperate for this radical agenda
they're willing to destroy the senate
democrats have a long list of partisan
bills that they'd like to pass
all these bills have two things in
common
they have nothing to do with improving
the lives of the american people as the
american people see it today
and they give more power to the democrat
politicians in washington d.c
let me remind my colleagues that there
is an election in november
in the last election cycle seven
democrats ran for president saying they
would change the rules of the senate
they all lost
democrats who said they changed the
rules lost senate races in swing states
including montana
maine and kentucky
american people have spoken loud and
clear
they don't want to see this democrat
power grab
american people want us to focus on
their priorities it's up to them to tell
us what's important to them
and what we're hearing loud and clear
from the american public it's
coronavirus it's inflation it's national
security it's crime it's securing the
border
not a bigger power grab for politicians
the democrats in this body seem to have
forgotten the people that they were
elected to serve
thank you mr president i yield the floor
who's who seeks recognition the senator
from delaware
thank you mr president
president and colleagues
as today's debate uh begins to wind down
i i want to rise to join those who have
called for the passage of
the freedom to vote act and the john
lewis voting rights
advancement act
years uh years ago when the united
states was in the early stages of a
conflict in vietnam i was fortunate to
win a navy rotc scholarship to attend to
ohio state
during my freshman year there
a spring break opposed our commanding
officer called in a bunch of us freshmen
midshipmen to say they said i got a deal
for you how'd you like to have an
all-expenses paid trip to quantico
virginia over spring break and that's
where the marine officers trained after
going to college
we all raised our hands and said
count us in
on the way uh
one day off we had five days in quantico
and more one day off we took a train to
union station in uh washington dc just
three or four blocks from here
from there most of my fellow midshipmen
found their way to watering holes in
georgetown
i chose to uh to visit capitol hill it's
a place i'd never been
that day i walked up delaware avenue and
passed this building somehow find my way
into the
uh rayburn house office building just a
short distance from where we're gathered
today
i walked up to a security officer there
and asked if there any hearings underway
that i might try to sit in on
he said yep
he directed me to a long
line in leading to the house judiciary
committee room and after a long wait
i finally had the chance to find a seat
and watch in person the debate over what
will later become the voting rights act
of 1965.
i was glued to that seat for hours
mesmerized by what i said
and what i heard
later
back on the train to quantico that uh
that evening
my friends asked me what i had found on
capitol hill
and that day and i told him i thought i
may have found
my future
and as it turned out
i did
that day and in the days to come those
hearings inspired by the civil rights
movement far a
spotlight
on the discriminatory state laws that
had made it nearly impossible for many
black americans
to vote 100 years after the end of the
civil war
years earlier my sister and i had grown
up in danville virginia the last capital
of the confederacy
there we saw racial discrimination up
close and personal
even as children we knew it was wrong
and we knew it had to change
sitting in rayburn years later
i found the place where i thought just
maybe
just maybe
i might be able to help do something
to right that wrong
nearly 18 years later
since sitting in that hearing room
after i finished my studies and
completed my third deployment to
southeast asia as a naval flight officer
during the vietnam war i found myself
back on capitol hill and these in these
halls
this time serving alongside of john
lewis and the house of representatives
and after years of blatant
discrimination and voter suppression
specifically targeted with black
americans
we began to witness change
it came slowly at first and then more
quickly
thanks to the tireless efforts of people
like our friend john lewis the voting
rights act of 1965 gained increasing
increasingly popular bipartisan support
over the years in fact as we've heard
earlier in fact by 2006 the vote to
extend the voting rights act was
unanimous imagine that 98 to zero think
about it 98 to zero and today 16 to the
90 of the
republican colleagues who voted for it
among those 98 are still here are still
here
given that history however it's almost
unbelievable to think that the right to
vote
is under attack once again in many parts
of our country today in states across
america state legislators and some
governors
are seeking to enact a wave of voter
restrictions many of them were the sole
person or sole purpose
of making it harder to vote often
specifically targeting black americans
in 2021 alone 19 states passed some 34
laws restricting the right to vote
how
well
by allowing partisan observers to
intimidate and pin independent poll
workers in texas
by pulling drop boxes and ballot
applications out of the hands of voters
and imposing penalties for poll workers
in florida who are just trying to do
their jobs
in georgia it's okay to make the poll
lines longer and longer but you can't
bring food or water to the voters who
wait in them sometimes for hours
to vote
hours
we know that in many parts of america
black voters have to wait in line for
twice as long as white voters to cast
their ballots
twice as long
and in some places for up to six hours
that's not just morally wrong and it's
an assault on who we are as a people
how can we look at what's happening and
not ask for god's sake can't we do
better than this
indeed we must
let me leave you with the one idea that
worked in 1965 and just might work again
in 2022.
you know every day across our country
americans gather in places of worship
every major religion in the world relies
on one common principle that bolsters
our connection to each other
golden rule
the idea that we should love our
neighbor as ourself
the idea that we ought to treat uh
people the way we want to be treated
most americans would be surprised to
learn that that ab
admonition is repeated almost weekly in
multiple bible studies and prayer
breakfasts that are regularly held here
on capitol hill throughout the year
it's a shared belief across religious
ethnic and party lines that the person
across from us
is just as valuable as us
just as deserving of love and dedication
as we are and our loved ones are
1965 the golden rule was a foundational
principle for equality in the voting
rights act
congress was guided by it in fact every
major religion on this planet embraces
it
i don't care if you're protestant
catholic jew
muslim hindu buddhist and it goes on the
golden rule is in your teachings and
your beliefs and you hear it here in
this this body in this building
week in and week out
maybe just maybe
it's about time we're just relying once
again
in this land of the free as we seek to
connect our values and our faith to our
actions
most of us so we'll recall that both dr
king and the preamble of our
constitution call on us to work to make
this a more perfect union
and fulfill the promise of our founders
that all men and women
are created equal
and while our country across our country
today we're seeing a growing wave of
voter restrictions i'm reminded of what
martin luther king said many years ago
he said this he said only when it's dark
enough can we see the stars think about
it only when it's dark enough
can we see the stars
sometimes it's only when we are tested
as a nation that our true spirit shows
itself i pray i pray that this is just
one such time
so while none of us hoped would ever
face uh these challenges in our
democracy to our democracy in the year
2022 perhaps we can take some comfort in
knowing that someone else has walked
this path before us all these years
later we feel that
fierce urgency of now that fierce
urgency of now that dr king spoke of
five years before
providing us both with a moral blueprint
and he encouraged me to do something
with that as i close let me just say
haven't said all that let me reiterate
that this is not a time to wait and
dawdle
congress needs to regroup
when we leave this building this day
this week and then act with the same
sense of urgency as a neural congress
earlier congress did in 1965 when it
passed the freedom to vote act and the
john lewis voting rights advancement act
in order to better protect the sacred
right to vote and uphold the sanctity of
our electoral processes
the la the legislation before us today
seeks to make clear what we as a nation
aspire to be
it makes clear that no one who is
eligible should be denied the sacred
right to vote
let me close our colleagues by observing
that in the end
we can quote dr king and praise my
friend john lewis until the cows come
home
but when americans sacred right to vote
is on the line it's our responsible to
uphold our oath to the constitution and
get on with it
i i don't know uh i never knew dr king i
knew john lewis know him well love him
but i don't know if dr king or john
lewis were fans of mark twain i am
and i want to close by paraphrasing the
words of mark twain
and this is that paraphrase when in
doubt
do what's right
you'll amaze your friends
and confound your enemies
well friends
time has come to do just that to do both
of those things
and that's why no barriers should stand
in the way of our sacred obligation to
protect this democracy and with that i
yield the floor thank you
mr president senator from idaho
mr president
the current uh voting rights
proposals or so-called voting rights
proposals that the democrats are
proposing
are not about increasing access to the
ballot box
according to the washington post
the 2020 election
saw the highest voter turnout in 120
years
and 94 percent of the voters said that
voting was easy
these bills are really
a power grab that would circumvent and
federalize our entire elections process
stripping states of their constitutional
authorities
these power grabs would force taxpayers
to pay for political campaigns
expand the practice of ballot harvesting
prohibit important voter id laws
keep deceased people and those who have
moved out of the area on registration
vote rolls
and federalize election laws which would
violate the u.s constitution's clear
directive that states administer the
elections
to name just a few
article 1 section 4 the united states
constitution
delegates election processes to the
states
this is a union of 50 states
states are the best equipped to
implement and enforce election policies
that protect the integrity of all future
elections
and although many who've spoken today
would have you believe that the states
across this nation are seeking to
violate the rights of american citizens
and restrict their access to voting this
the laws that are being proposed and
adopted by the states are doing just the
opposite
they are helping to expand voter access
and improve security at the polls
there are a lot of myths and untruths
running rampant
because the democrats seem to want the
public to think there is this widespread
voter suppression
in republican-led states
which there is not
a couple of myths and the facts
myth republican state legislatures are
enacting laws that will roll back early
voting
the fact is
that the states are expanding early
voting
george's bill for example which has been
attacked
allows for and provides for mandates 17
days of early voting with two additional
optional sundays of early voting
the list goes on arizona allows 30 or 26
days iowa allows 20 days texas another
state that has been attacked allows 17
days
the fact is the states are expanding
early voting
myth
states are implementing voter id for
mail for vote by mail in order to
disenfranchise voters
the facts
as vote by mail is increasing in the
states
and states the states are implementing
some of the same safeguards the same
safeguards
that are used for in-person voting to
ensure a secure election
such as voter id
which the legislation before us seems to
want to prohibit
recent polls show that 80 percent of the
people support
being required to show id in order to
vote
including 62 percent of democrats
myth
prohibiting ballot harvesting and
requiring people to vote in their own
correct
precinct
constitute discrimination
outlawed by the voting rights act
fact
in a recent supreme court case
the court ruled six 6-3 against this
claim
arizona law mandates that voters must
vote in their assigned precinct and
those who vote early by mail cannot have
anyone other than a household member a
family member a caregiver a postal
worker or an elections official collect
their ballot in other words supervised
ballot collection
this law effectively bans the practice
of ballot harvesting
the democrats seem to want to expand
even mandate ballot harvesting in the
legislation we are being asked to
support tonight
myth
states are improperly purging eligible
voters from the voter rolls
fact
states are taking reasonable measures to
ensure their voter rolls are accurate
which makes elections more efficient and
fair
states are simply implementing a
time-honored practice of cleaning up
voter lists removing voters who have
died or who have moved
or who have been declared incompetent by
a court or convicted of a felony a
time-honored practice in many of the
states across this nation
myth
recent changes in georgia to prevent
people from giving bottles of water is
inhumane and targets minority
communities
fact
the law allows poll workers to set up
self-serve water stations for voters to
use
the statute prevents political
organizations
political organizations
from giving people
in line things like meals water or gifts
once again
this is a long
time honored practice in our states this
law of anti-electioneering or anti-vote
buying is standard practice in many
states including many of my colleagues
blue states like new york new jersey and
president biden's home state of delaware
so let's get on to the
filibuster the argument is since the
republicans won't accept these wrong
directed uh reforms so-called reforms of
our election laws that we should
eliminate the filibuster in the senate
that is the last thing that should be
done in the senate
president biden himself has argued
against eliminating the filibuster and
according to a recent report democrats
used that filibuster over 300 times in
2020
in 2005 then senator joe biden gave a
passionate floor speech defending the
senate filibuster
saying that this is a key procedural
tool and it's ending it would eviscerate
the senate and do a disservice to the
country and would upset the
constitutional design
in another floor speech then senator
biden further argued the reason
republicans in congress were attempting
to end the filibuster was because they
controlled every level of government
he went on to point out that the reason
to have the filibuster rule
was so that when one party controls all
levers of government
one man or one woman can stand on the
floor of the senate and resist the
passions of the moment
again in 2005 senator chuck schumer
also said that eliminating the
filibuster would be a doomsday for
democracy
that would turn our country into a in
his words banana republic
former senator senator robert byrd of
west virginia
wrote about preserving the filibuster
we've heard it many times today
he said we must never ever tear down the
only wall
the necessary fence that this nation has
against the excesses of the executive
branch and the resultant haste and
tyranny of the majority
he went on to say the senate has been
the last fortress of minority rights and
freedom of speech in this republic for
more than two centuries
and he said i pray that senators will
pause and reflect before ignoring that
history and tradition in favor of the
political priority of the moment
as leader mcconnell quoted on the floor
yesterday the smallest majority we've
seen in our politics is trying to change
the rules for how people get elected in
every state
you may recall republicans were asked to
do this exact thing
when we controlled every lever of
government and we refused to make that
change because of the importance of the
filibuster to this institution
eliminating or weakening the legislative
filibuster would destroy the intentional
design of the senate by the world's most
deliberative body
it would allow any small majority in the
senate to strip the voice of millions of
americans considered in the minority
removing the filibus the ability to
filibuster legislation would reduce the
incentive for the senate to forge broad
agreements and force further debate and
would likely increase divisiveness
rather than efficiency
i urge my colleagues to vote against
this federal takeover of our state's
constitutional right to manage their own
elections
and i urge my colleagues to reject this
unfounded assault on the senate
filibuster
thank you mr president
[Music]
senator from vermont
mr president this has been an
interesting
day of debate it actually feels good to
hear people really speak on an issue
as president pro tem i've sat in that
chair where
my distinguished friend from maine is
sitting now
as presiding officer i sat there for
hours today
and listened to the debates
and heard many
i found extremely good
and then i heard some others
but i appreciate the fact that i had the
opportunity as president pro tem to hear
so many uh other senators in both
parties speak
you know i spoke yesterday about
protecting everyone's vote on a ballot
and how important that is
i know that because of my own state of
vermont and when i first ran it was a
very republican state
i've been on the ballot between my times
as states attorney and senator
between primaries and general elections
i've been on the ballot
in vermont 24 times
i never
questioned
that the ballots would be counted
accurately
and honestly
even though in several of the elections
80 to 90 percent of the people
uh counting the ballots
were the town clerks and their
republicans
[Music]
we have order in the senate please take
your conversation off the floor thank
you
so after those
24 times i think i have some idea of how
they said it works
and i can also say it with seniority
comes a bit of experience
and this is my 48th year here in the u.s
senate
having been elected by those same
vermonters i praised for the way they
protect the sanctity of the ballot 47 uh
eight times
still the only democrats in the united
states said it by the voters of vermont
i've become the chairman of the
appropriations committee
the former chairman and ranking member
of the
judiciary and agriculture committee
and then honored three times to be
elected
as president pro tempore
so i let me just take a couple of
minutes with your indulgence mr
president talk about what the senate was
what it has become and what it can be
again
i think my experience qualifies me to
say that my conscience compels me to say
that
each of us stand on the shoulders of
giants
and the centers from across the
political spectrum
from around this nation to forge a path
for america
they met the moment of the time not with
timidity or fear
but with action
with decisiveness
now was the road taken an easy one
no
was the struggle short no
but was it worth the sacrifice
the dedication
the commitment
and yet it's a compromise to meet it of
course
but before the senate today is the issue
that's at the heart of our very
government the right to vote
the one thing we can hold sacred no
matter what party we belong to
the right to vote
time and time again the constitution has
been amended
to expand the right to vote not to
restrict it but to expand it
look at the 15th amendment the 19th the
24th the 26th
these each
gave greater access to the ballot box
for more americans
it furthered the shared goal that ours
be the most exclusive
and most democratic nation on earth
but today we do have a scourge of laws
no matter what we see on the floor
the facts are we have a scourge of laws
making their way through partisan
legislatures across the country
they roll back the tides of time eroding
the most fundamental right all the time
when technology and pure common sense
should tell us that voting should be a
lot more accessible
than it is
and coupled with a challenge from the
supreme court that congress
affirmatively act remember this the
supreme court said why didn't the
congress step in there and act to
restore the long
bipartisan voting rights act
there's no more important time than now
for us to meaningful
meaningfully address this constitutional
right
this foundational right
now there's some honest questions to ask
here of ourselves of each other do we
really want to make it more difficult
for americans to vote legally and safely
is that what democracy means to you
to me
do we really want to allow states to
make it more difficult
for blue-collar workers or the poor or
the disadvantage to vote
when the great advances of time and
technology are there
where
you can easily make it
easier
easier to vote not more difficult
are we really going to turn back the
clock to an era where state and local
jurisdictions
can blatantly discriminate against
certain voters
yes people color minority populations
by simply rigging the systems of voting
or accounting or changing the map
to raise the progress of generations
make meaningless the fights of lions
like john lewis dr martin luther king jr
and so many others
is that really what we stand for
in this century
were we elected by our constituents to
flatly obstruct any action this body
simply because our party is not in the
majority
or were we elected
to
tacitly agree with a prescribed agenda
the senate
those who stand in it owe more to our
constituents and to this nation than
blind party loyalty
we owe it to the nation to do what is
right we owe it to our conscience to do
what's right
partisan disagreements division
stalemates
dot the pages of our young nation's
history when you go back and read it
but it's the more it's the moments of
bipartisanship
to punctuate it
so i'd ask the question of our two
leaders
mr majority leader should we not have a
debate a real debate in these issues
with amendments unbound by
deadlines or time limits
but in answering that i also ask the
minority leader
do we not have an obligation to america
to your constituents in my
to at least talk about these issues
are for honest and meaningful proposals
then vote them up or vote them down
are we not intended
to be the greatest liberative body in
the world
probably was when i came here but these
days we surely are not
in history we remember this moment
a moment
when we stood for the foundational right
of our democracy the right to vote or we
stood against it
how long have i
long if i sit on this floor
that the conscience of the nation rests
in the united states senate
or should
today we each of us sworn to uphold the
constitution
as a member of this great body that we
must examine our conscience
we must decide whether it be the
politics of exclusion
or the justice
of inclusion
to be the indelible mark of the 117th
congress
we must decide the senate envisioned by
our founders could be restored
the giants the lions of the senate the
members arise above to meet these
moments and have the courage
to do what is right
for our job or easy anyone could do it
but throughout history
fewer than 2 000 americans
have had the honor the privilege the
responsibility
to hold the title of the united states
senator
i've been proud to serve
with one out of every five of those
senators
some i agreed with some i disagreed with
i could say this we
100 here today are caretakers of a
legacy far greater than our own
we shoulder the responsibility of a
nation a nation
founded under the principle
the governments are
instituted among his people
deriving their just powers from the
consent of the government
and i fear that if we let this moment
this pivotal moment pass a spy with no
debate no action no advancement
would not only be derelict in our duty
but we'll betray the very oath we swore
when we
stood in front of the desk
you're sitting in mr president
we pledge to defend the constitution
to continue the endless goal of forming
a more perfect union
we should pass the freedom to vote the
john r lewis act
but we should at the very least
have the courage to debate it
i feel such a privilege
serving vermont
i feel such a privilege to have been on
the ballot 24 times
in our state
because i can always trust
that everybody who wanted to vote could
today we have the technology we have the
ability to have far more people vote
don't we owe it to this country
don't we owe it to our oath of office
to do that i yield the floor
mr president
another senator from vermont all right
we're running out of senators for
vermont i think that's it
um
mr president let me uh begin by thanking
a number of my senate colleagues
who have worked so hard on this issue
uh let me thank among others senator
merkley klobuchar booker warnock king
leahy durbin kane and others for their
efforts on this important issue
mr president i will be brief
uh because there is not a whole lot that
i can add to the excellent statements
that so many other senators have made
but let me just say this
for some the issue we are debating today
may seem complicated
to be understood only
by lawyers constitutional scholars
and those handful of people
who actually understand the opaque rules
of the u.s senate
so i just want to say that if that is
what you think
you're wrong
what we are debating today is not
complicated
it is really quite simple
and here is what it's about
joe biden won
the 2020 presidential election period
you may have liked that result or you
may not have liked it but he won
he won in an election that donald
trump's own department of homeland
security determined to be the most
secure election in american history
after the election trump and his
supporters filed more than 60 lawsuits
in state and federal courts
repeating their false claims
and trying to reverse the election
results
these lawsuits were rejected time and
time again
including
with judges that trump himself appointed
nonetheless the former president
continued to claim and to this day
continues to claim despite all of the
evidence
that the election was stolen
and that he actually won
in a landslide
not only are his statements and actions
delusional
they are worse
in repeating this big lie over and over
again
he not only cast doubts about the 2020
election
but in fact in a disgraceful
and
unprecedented way for a president
he is undermining the very foundations
of american democracy
shamefully
republican leaders all across this
country
including republican members of the u.s
senate
either repeated trump's lies
or tried to walk a very very thin line
around them
trump's one-man dominance over the
republican party is now so strong
that few republican officials are
prepared to state openly
what they know
in their hearts to be true
and that is that trump is a pathological
liar
and a threat to democracy in this
country and our very way of life
in any case
the predictable result of all of this
was that republican governors and
legislatures all over this country
saw trump's big lie and fear-mongering
as an opportunity a golden opportunity
to solidify their political positions
acting under the guise of voter
integrity
despite the fact that our nation has
very
little voter fraud thank god
they proceeded to pass election laws in
19 states
that make it harder for people to vote
with a special focus
on people of color
young people poor people and people with
disabilities
people who might be
inclined to vote
against them
in many cases they also created election
districts through extreme gerrymandering
that have no rationale
other than to make certain that
republicans retain control over state
legislatures
in other cases they are cutting back on
the authority of independent election
officials
and giving that power
to partisan legislatures
today
in order to address this crisis in
american democracy
members of the senate will be casting
two
very important votes
the first will be the freedom to vote
act
and this bill goes a long way
to end voter suppression and in fact
make it easier not harder for american
citizens to vote
it establishes automatic voter
registration and online voter
registration it celebrates democracy by
making election day a national holiday
holiday
so the people can vote at a time other
than after work
it establishes uniform early voting and
same-day registration
this bill also ends partisan
gerrymandering and roots out the undue
influence of special interest money in
buying election imagine that
imagine that we would actually know the
names of billionaires who put huge
amounts of money into super pacs
that by election what a terrible thing
we'd actually know who these people are
this bill will also provide increased
protection
in the voting process for voters with
disabilities
the military overseas voters and
underserved communities and much much
more this is a very significant piece of
legislation now why would anybody be
opposed to it
why in a nation that has a history
of denying the vote to african americans
denying the vote to native americans
denying the vote to women and denying
the vote to low-income whites
why would any fair-minded person be in
opposition to make it easier for all
citizens to vote
that's what i understood when i went to
elementary school you know you play by
the rules you do your best sometimes you
win
and sometimes you lose that's the
process
but no one ever told me that what
politics is about
is working overtime to try to prevent
people from voting
just because they might vote against you
our job should be to increase voter
turnout make it easier for people to
participate which is what this
legislation does
i want this country to have the highest
voter turnout of any nation on earth not
one of the lowest
but let's be clear
this enormously important bill
a bill to protect the foundations of
american democracy
will
fail it will fail because according to
senate rules
it will require 60 votes to pass
and in a 50-50 senate
not one republican
will vote for it
it will likely get 50 votes which with
the vice president casting the
tie-breaking vote
would be enough to pass this legislation
under majority
rule
it will not get 60 votes
all of which brings us to the second
vote
which is really the most important vote
of the day
that vote will determine
whether anything we discuss today
whether any of the speeches that we give
any of the points that we actually make
will in fact become law
and that is the vote to change senate
rules
and establish a talking filibuster
a process which gives the minority
an enormous amount of time to object to
legislation and voice their concerns
the minority whether it is a democratic
minority or a republican minority would
have days and days and days to slow the
process down to rally the american
people around their ideas
but they would not have
forever
at the end of the time
allotted
a majority vote would prevail
which in my view is what a democratic
society
is all about
is changing
the senate rules a radical idea oh my
god
first time in history we're about to do
it
never been done before oh well really
not quite no
because every member of the senate knows
the rules get changed on a fairly
regular basis
nothing radical about it
just a few months ago
in order to raise the debt ceiling
and prevent our government from
defaulting on its loans
the rules were
changed so that a 50-vote majority
would prevail
we changed the rules appropriately
and we prevented a default
and a massive worldwide depression
just a few years ago
my republican colleagues who were so
adamantly against
changing rules
well my goodness
they changed the senate rules
to allow 50 votes to confirm the
president's nominees to the supreme
court
oh my goodness how shocking
and they got three conservative supreme
court justices as a result
rules get changed around here all of the
time
and maybe just maybe we might want to
change the rules
in order to save american democracy
now let me conclude by saying this i
don't know if any of my other colleagues
have made this point but i will
i regard it as a very sad day
for our country and i mean this very
sincerely
that not one republican in this body
is prepared to vote for this bill
now i understand why that is the case i
am in politics i got it i know who the
leader of their party is
but this i do not understand i can
understand republicans but this i do not
understand
i do not understand why two democrats
who presumably understand the importance
of the freedom to vote act
and as i understand it will vote
for the freedom to vote act
are not prepared to change the rules so
that that bill
could actually become
law
that i do not understand
if you think this bill makes sense
and if you're worried about the future
of american democracy and if you are
prepared to vote for the bill
then why are you wasting everybody's
time and not voting for the rule change
that allows us to pass the bill
you know it's like inviting somebody to
lunch putting out a great spread and
saying you can't eat
if you're gonna vote for the bill vote
to change
the rules
mr president
if we can change the rules to prevent
a default on our national debt
if we can change the rules to confirm
supreme court justices
we can certainly change the rules to
save american democracy thank you
[Music]
mr president
the senator from georgia
thank you mr president
mr president
abraham lincoln must be turning in his
grave
to hear the senators from the grand old
party
the party of abolition and emancipation
and reconstruction
echoing the state's rights rhetoric of
dixiecrat segregationists
to oppose federal voting rights
legislation
to oppose even
the reauthorization of the voting rights
act
the voting rights act of 1965.
in 2021 just one republican senator
had the courage
and principle
to vote to restore
the voting rights act of 1965 the
senator from alaska senator murkowski
just one
for decades
the reauthorization of the voting rights
act was bipartisan
today
only one republican senator
will stand up for this landmark
achievement
of the civil rights movement
not senator cornyn of texas
who previously said the voting rights
act is simply the most important and
most effective civil rights legislation
ever passed bar none
no longer his position
not my friend the senator from maine
senator collins
who previously said this bill will
ensure that the voting rights afforded
to all americans are protected
not senator burr of north carolina
who previously said voting rights for
all american citizens regardless of race
are granted by the 15th amendment and
enforced by the voting rights act and
not the minority leader
who previously said this is a good piece
of legislation which has served an
important purpose over many years
and this landmark piece of legislation
will continue to make a difference not
only in the south but for all americans
and for all of us whether we are
african-americans or not not the
minority leader
the same minority leader who said this
bill eliminated the barriers to voting
so that all americans could participate
in the basic opportunity each of us have
who celebrated quote we have renewed the
voting rights act periodically since
that time overwhelmingly and on a
bipartisan basis year after year because
members of congress realize that this is
a piece of legislation that has worked
no more not in 2022
only one republican senator
stood up to support the voting rights
act of 1965.
when congressman john lewis and hosea
williams and amelia boynton and hundreds
of others marched across the edmund
pettus bridge on bloody sunday when john
lewis had his skull fractured on that
bridge
for daring to demand the right to vote
for black americans in the american
south it was the example of their
courage
and their sacrifice
that paved the way for passage
of the voting rights act of 1965.
as my colleague my brother senator
reverend warnock has often observed when
congressman lewis passed
there were many in this chamber on both
sides
who rightly celebrated his towering
achievements
and his legacy
but i speak for the state of georgia
when i say do not invoke congressman
lewis name to signal your virtue
while you work to erode his legacy
and defy his will
i've heard a lot from our republican
colleagues about
the recently passed election law in the
state of georgia
let's be very clear there is no one in
georgia on either side of the aisle who
doubts or does not understand precisely
what its purpose is
forbidding voter registration for runoff
elections
driving down the early vote period
during decisive runoffs to drive up
lines at majority black precincts
as he used to say john lewis didn't give
a little blood on that bridge that day
so that black georgians would have to
wait eight times longer to vote
than white georgians
john lewis didn't give a little bit of
blood on that bridge that day
so that state legislatures across this
country could pass legislation
surgically targeted to make it harder
for some people to vote
all for partisan power
in the state of georgia where now
partisan election officials
can step in and throw out locally
elected election boards
to change who can vote and where they
can vote
this in the aftermath of a well-known
incident when the former president of
the united states threatened georgia's
secretary of state with criminal
prosecution
if he didn't quote find 11 000 votes
that were never cast for donald trump
the facts of the former president's
efforts to seize reelection despite his
defeat are well known
he and his lieutenants mounted an
unprecedented campaign
to retain power based on a torrent of
lies that have grievously wounded public
confidence in our elections
and it was only thanks to the integrity
of our laws and our courts
and principled election officials
and the will of congress the will of
this senate mr president
to ensure the peaceful transition of
power in the face of a violent assault
on the u.s capitol
that this conspiracy was defeated
so now this faction seeks to dismantle
precisely those bulwarks
which prevented their onslaught from
succeeding
the choice is ours
whether we will allow them to do so
we in the united states congress
madam vice president
have the constitutional authority to
make the laws with respect to the
administration of federal elections
we in the united states senate have an
obligation
to defend the legacy of congressman john
lewis
to stand up for the sacred franchise to
secure equal access to the ballot for
every single american voter
so that this country can continue its
journey
toward full realization
of our founding ideals
i yield the floor madam vice president
[Music]
so
madam vice president the senator from
georgia
thank you madam vice president
we have been summoned here by history
this is not just another routine day in
the senate this is a moral moment
in america
and i recall the words of that great
american patriot and
prophet martin luther king jr
whose birthday all of us just observed
as he agonized over the difficulty and
complexity
of that moral moment
dr king said history has thrust
something upon me
from which i cannot turn away
we have been summoned here
all of us
we cannot turn away
and this is no time for politics as
usual
the times cry out for moral leadership
for integrity
for empathy
and for care for one another
deep investment in the covenant that we
have with one another as an american
people
e pluribus unum
out of many one
what a grand doctrine
what a noble idea
which our country has been striving to
reach with fits and starts with
setbacks and comebacks
since the day of its founding
this is one of those moments
we cannot turn away
we cannot hide from history
and i am truly honored to stand here
with all of you democrats republicans
and independents
in this
moment and on this my
365th date
as a member of the united states senate
the most
consequential deliberative body on the
planet striving again for greatness
i was elected from georgia
on january 5th
what an honor to represent the people of
the state of georgia
and what a great nation
a kid from the caton homes housing
projects
the first
college graduate
in my family of 12 my folks are both
preachers they read the scriptures be
fruitful and multiply
this kid
who grew up in poverty now serving in
the united states senate
only the 11th black senator in the whole
history of our nation
and during that same time georgia also
elected its first jewish senator
my brother john ossoff
i believe that somewhere in glory dr
martin luther king jr and rabbi
abraham jeshua abraham joshua heschel
are smiling
because they marched together
rabbi heschel said that when he marched
without the king he felt like his legs
were praying
and so what a moment
i won after a hard-fought election
and the next morning i was feeling
pretty good
my mother who grew up in waycross
georgia
picking cotton as a teenager had joined
with other georgians and record voter
turnout and the 82 year old hands that
used to pick somebody else's cotton
helped to pick her youngest son to be a
u.s senator only in america is my story
even possible
i was on several of the morning shows
talking about what the people of georgia
had achieved and i was feeling pretty
good
that morning
man i was on the view talking to whoopi
goldberg
[Laughter]
but by lunchtime the news alerts
on my phone began to buzz
something was happening in the capitol
and we all know the rest of that sad and
tragic story
a violent assault on our nation's
capital
driven by the big lie
ugly words signs and symbols of racism
and anti-semitism
an effort to stop the legal
certification of an election and in
spite of those who want to hide sadly
january 6 really did happen
and we must face up to it
we cannot hide from history
january 6 happened but here's the thing
january 5th also happened
georgia a state in the old confederacy
sent a black man and a jewish man to the
senate in one fell swoop
our nation has always had a complicated
history and i submit to you that here's
where we are
we are swinging from a moral dilemma we
we are caught somewhere between january
5th and january 6th
between our hopes and our fears
between bigotry and beloved community
and in each moment we the people have to
decide which way are we going to go and
what are we willing to sacrifice in
order to get there
the question today is are we going to
give in to a violent attack whose aim is
now being pursued through partisan voter
suppression laws in state legislatures
sadly georgia the same georgia
that sent me and my brother ossoff to
the senate
not the people of georgia partisan state
politicians
have decided to punish their own
citizens for having the audacity
to show up
and it isn't
just about the restrictions
around water
and food distribution
the more fundamental question is why the
last so long in the first place
and why is that the case in certain
communities i know
of so many of your fellow americans
we need empathy
compassion care for one another
while local election officials working
in lincoln county georgia to close all
but one polling location for a county
that's bigger than 250 square miles
why is the second most powerful
legislator in the georgia state senate
working right now to pass legislation to
eliminate all ballot drop boxes in
georgia in the middle of a pandemic
why state leaders in georgia right now
working to take over the local elections
board in fulton county
wherever needs a baptist church sits
there's a woman in cobb county named
irish
she says she's tried repeatedly over the
past 10 years to vote
but could not because of long lines and
changing polling locations
people playing games
she said that she has
often had to decide if she will work
or vote
another woman verona from cobb county
says that she waited in line for eight
hours in the rain at her local library
eight hours to vote
i run into constituents all the time who
tell me
that they waited for hours to vote for
me
i'm honored that they vote voted for me
but i'm sad that they should have to
wait for eight hours
a student in atlanta named isabella
says that she and many of her friends
who could not vote in the november 2020
election because they did not want to
skip class to stand in line
why are state leaders in georgia
behaving as if
giving voters these awful choices is
normal
or that voters like these georgians
don't exist
those are the facts of the laws
that are being passed in georgia
and across our nation
so here's the question tonight
america
are we january 5th or are we january 6th
are we going to give in to the forces
that seek to divide us by gerrymandering
us suppressing us and subverting the
voices of some of us in pursuit of power
at any cost or are we going to live up
to that grand american covenant e
pluribus unum
out of many
one
i choose what dr king called beloved
community
i choose america
i choose a nation that embraces all of
us
we've been summoned here
we cannot turn away
and in just a few moments all 100 of us
blessed with a sacred trust
we'll let the american people know where
we stand on the question of whether the
senate will protect their voices the
voices of the very people who sent us
here
or if we will simply surrender
to the anti-democratic fervor and
polarizing this unity spreading across
our nation
in the meantime let me say
that i am glad that we are finally
actually having a debate
on the senate floor imagine that
the senate
what is that the most important
deliberative body
is actually
having a debate
it took us nearly a year to get to this
point and i want to thank my colleagues
who worked
with me and others over the last many
months to keep this critical issue on
the senate's front burner voting rights
are preservative of all other rapes
the democracy is the framework in which
all other debates take place we can
strengthen our infrastructure and the
infrastructure of our democracy at the
same time if we can change the rules to
raise the debt ceiling we can change the
rules to raise and repair the ceiling of
our democracy this is our work
so we have crafted
a strong piece
of compromised legislation
that will address the rampant voter
suppression and election subversion laws
we're seeing pass and state after state
after state 19 so far and counting
the freedom to vote john
r lewis act
will restore bed right bedrock voting
protections
established by the voting rights act of
1965
protections that have been eroded by the
supreme court
and are born from an era where members
of this body used to work together to
solve the tough issues of our time
it will also set a federal baseline for
voting standards to ensure every
eligible voter has access to the ballot
no matter where they live
and to protect elections from subversion
by craven politicians
voting rights should be bipartisan used
to be bipartisan
pass this body to last time 98 to zero
signed into law by george w bush a
republican president
and i know that
my colleagues and i have worked in good
faith this past year this entire year we
have worked hard to try and find some
common ground with our republican
friends on this issue
i've said to my colleagues
let us bring these measures to the floor
to debate let's reason
let's deliberate
and i had hoped our friends on the other
side would have allowed us to have a
debate on voting rights legislation but
until today that's what they blocked
three times in the senate they didn't
block the bills they blocked our ability
to even have a debate on the bills
as a pastor i understand the power and
the possibility of coming together
with those with whom we disagree
to have a robust debate on the issues
that are important to families and to
our country i i share with many of you
i'm sure a vision of the senate that
collaborates
and negotiates
on the most important issues of our time
i believe in bipartisanship
when it comes to something as
fundamental as voting rights
i just have to ask bipartisanship
at what cost
who is being to ask who is being asked
to foot the bill for this bipartisanship
and is liberty itself the cost i submit
that that's cost to hide a bridge too
far
i'm deeply saddened
that our republican colleagues
chose not to join us in this effort
democrats would prefer not to act alone
but by all means we have to act
even if we don't get it done tonight we
have to keep working at it until we get
it done
dr king's words are as true now as they
were back then history has thrust
something upon me from which i cannot
turn
away he said justice delayed is justice
denied
now i know that i've been speaking a lot
over the course of the last year about
voting rights
and it is one of my one of my primary
passions
but i'm thrilled to work for georgians
to close the medicaid coverage gap in
our state to create new good paying jobs
and growing and emerging industries to
strengthen broadband across our state
and more i'm thrilled to fight for these
priorities for georgia because that's
what georgian sent me here to do but
they sent me with their votes
but how can we have productive
conversations about the many issues
affecting the american people about
lowering health care costs
about creating good paying jobs about
fighting climate change protecting
reproductive health care if politicians
and states get to cherry-pick their
voters
and the people's voices are squeezed out
of their democracy
how can we achieve real consensus on the
issues that matter most if only some
voters can be heard
taking action to pass voting rights
legislation is not a policy argument
it is about the democracy itself
voting rights is how we address the
deepening divides in our country
by ensuring every eligible voter's voice
is heard
and we as elected representatives have
an obligation to protect
their voice
so when it comes to the question of
procedure
and the filibuster
let me be clear
i believe that voting rights are more
important
than a procedural rule
and if taking action requires a change
in the rules then it is time to change
the rules
when the times changed
we have always changed the rules
160 times
and as we consider the filibuster the
name
[Music]
of the senator from west virginia
robert byrd inevitably comes up
his is an important perspective
but we shouldn't quote him
as if he is scripture
in fact
he didn't always get it right
he said his greatest regret was
filibustering the
1964 civil rights bill
robert byrd learn from history will we
now
madam president as i
continue on what may feel like a
filibuster
some point to senate procedure
while others recycle excuses we've heard
before
but as the pastor of ebenezer baptist
church i also know that all of these
arguments against taking the moral
action we're called to take are
distractions
consider this
there are some things you can do in this
chamber
with just 51 votes
confirm confirmed supreme court nominee
51.
pass trillions of dollars in investments
for our communities 51.
pass massive tax cuts
mainly for the riches of the rich 51.
confirm cabinet nominees 51.
raise the debt ceiling we found a way to
do it the other week
51.
but it takes 60 votes to repair the
ceiling of our democracy by passing
voting rights legislation i'm left to
conclude
that if the issue is important enough
the senate feels compelled to act
well let me say that i believe that the
democracy is at least as important as
the economy
recently many of our colleagues have
argued that legislation to protect
voting rights somehow offends our
federal system of government and amounts
they say to a federal takeover of
elections
some of the same voices ironically
who have extolled dr king's life this
week
have at the same time been working
vigorously against the legislation we're
debating today to protect the right to
vote and many of them have been
channeling old states rights arguments
let the message go out
you cannot remember martin luther king
jr and dismember his legacy at the same
time
you can argue whatever side you want
but you do not get to argue both sides
i will not sit quietly while some make
dr king a victim of identity theft
you do not get to offer praises and
plotters in memory of dr king and then
martial the same kinds of states rights
arguments that were used against dr king
and against the civil rights movement
please know that as the pastor of dr
king's church this this argument evokes
i say really respectfully it evokes some
of the darkest moments in our country's
longest long struggle for equality
when the supreme court ruled that school
segregation was unconstitutional
and brown versus board of education
after a century of jim crow laws
arkansas governor orville
farbes
did not argue that he supported
segregation at all costs
he instead claimed that obeying the
brown decision amounted to a surrender
of all our rights he said as citizens to
an all-powerful federal autocracy
when u.s senator trump thurman launched
the longest filibuster in the history of
the united states against a bill to
protect voting rights he didn't argue
explicitly that black people didn't
deserve to vote he instead claimed that
it was quote unlawful and
unconstitutional for congress to
to regulate the elections of the states
and during the senate 60-day debate on
the civil rights act of 1964 the closing
argument of the bill's opponents led and
articulated
by georgia senator richard b russell
was that it would quote strike down and
destroy many rights and powers which
since the foundation of our government
have properly belonged to several states
let's be very clear about this
legislation the states will continue to
administer their elections
and of course states have certain rights
but do we genuinely believe that states
have a right to discriminate
to suppress
or to block access to ballot boxes for
so many americans
although we have 50 unique states we are
also united as one republic
and what happens in one state can affect
us all when we elect our u.s senators
and our u.s representatives and when we
elect the president we must represent
all americans we need every vote to
count to maintain the integrity of our
democracy
and so we must do this work
i support reforming the electoral
account act
that said reforming the electoral
account act will do virtually nothing to
address the sweeping voter suppression
and election diversion efforts taking
place in georgia and in states and
localities nationwide it doesn't matter
if your votes are properly counted if
you cannot cast your vote in the first
place
and so as i close
i want to appeal to all of my colleagues
on both sides of the aisle
not just as a colleague but as a pastor
and
as a man of faith
the american people have sent us here
and history has summoned us to this
moment
we cannot hide
whatever the outcome tonight i
still
believe
in us
i believe in the us
i believe in us i believe that democracy
is the political enactment of a
spiritual idea that we're all children
of god and therefore we all ought to
have a voice in the direction of our
country and our destiny within it i
believe that a vote is a kind of prayer
for the world we desire for ourselves
and for our children and that our
prayers are stronger
when we pray together
and so a young martin luther king jr
struggled all those years ago
and he said history has thrust something
upon me from which i cannot turn away
those of us who are students of dr king
i know i have often wondered
what would i have done if i were alive
during the civil rights movement
i know we would all like to think that
we too would have had just a small
fraction just a fraction of the courage
that it took for john lewis to cross
that edmond pettus bridge
well
for those of us who are fortunate enough
to serve in the united states senate in
this moment
in this moral moment
we do not have to wonder
my god he he faced
troopers on the other side crossing that
bridge we're talking about a procedural
bridge
we don't have to wonder what we would
have done
i submit that what we would have done
back then we are doing right now
history is watching us
our children are counting on us
and i hope that we will have the courage
to do what is right for our communities
and for our country the courage to cross
this bridge to do the hard work in this
defining moral moment in america for the
sake of the communities that sent us
here in the first place for the sake of
the planet for the sake of health care
for the sake of jobs for the sake of
being able to argue for the things that
we care about
the courage to fight for one another
i'm still praying that we will cross
that bridge
but if not tonight
we will come back
again
and again
and again
madam vice president i yield the floor
mr president madam president
majority leader just for a minute i want
to first salute
the amazing speeches by our two senators
from georgia
georgia which has been the crucible in
our fight for voting rights where the
attempts to curtail voting rights seem
most pernicious
to both of you
your erudition
your eloquence your passion
were amazing and i want to salute our
republican colleagues who listen to the
speeches and hope that those who weren't
here will get a chance to review those
speeches as well
now i ask unanimous consent that the
mandatory quorum call with respect to
the pending cloture motion be waived
is there an objection
without objection i ask unanimous
consent the following senators be
permitted to complete their remarks
prior to the scheduled vote senator
blunt senator klobuchar senator schumer
is there objection
without objection
madam vice president senator mary i've
been on the floor most of the day today
i think i've heard virtually every
speech given i was reminded again
as the day went on
of really the broad-based talent of
people in the senate i spent some time a
couple of years ago i spent over a
course of about six months
kind of watching individual senators and
trying to figure out how they got here
and with only a couple of exceptions i
could figure it out
that unique ability to
communicate or to explain things in a
way that people understood them
or to appear to just know more than
other people knew about things that
people knew senators need to know about
and i was reminded again of the tragedy
of how little we use that collected
talent
it's absolutely no telling what we could
do if we would decide as a hundred
people who figured out how to get to the
united states senate
how we'd work together and solve big
problems
and i think we all know where we are
today but i do hope as senator schumer
mentioned
that we listened to each other as people
expressed different views
certainly the senate would be a better
place if we
spent more time on the floor listening
to each other and talking to each other
on this bill i think we all know where
we're headed
in my view
having watched election legislation for
a long time
it seems to me this is just another
version of a election bill
introduced by democrats there's not much
new in this bill
both the rules committee where i serve
and the senate have already rejected
this federal takeover election several
times this year
now many of my friends on the other side
said
well why wouldn't republicans just want
to debate this bill
i don't think anybody said why wouldn't
the republicans want to amend this bill
because there was no opportunity to do
that
you know we've been on the bill now for
several days
got on the bill
fairly crafty way to get on the bill
with the 51 vote vote fine with me to be
on the bill
but but our friends on the other side
decided there'd be no amendments on this
bill
and i think republicans from the very
start sense that this would be a bill
where we'd get a yes or no vote on a
bill that really
would dramatically change
how we pursue elections now while it has
a new name
it's more than 700 pages it's nearly
identical to the
freedom to vote act it's substantially
the same as the two
versions that couldn't get 50 on that
side of the
s1
very similar to the senate bill h.r one
and very similar frankly
to the election bills that i've been
watching for 20 years
and there's always been a different
reason to do about the same
democrat sponsored bill house and senate
after 2020
the reason was well the
equipment is too faulty
and we've got to have more federal
control of what happens in the states
after 2016 the reason to have a massive
election bill
was was just not enough security in
state elections and the federal
government has to intervene in some
major way
after 2020 even though the federal
government didn't intervene in a major
way
suddenly the elections were the most
secure in the history of the world
both parties allege that at one point
uh and now we need to have this bill
because some states are passing
legislation that in most cases looks at
the real outreach
that they appropriately did for the
pandemic
and thinking in 2021
that the pandemic was over thinking what
do we want to keep of what we did in
that outreach
and what do we want to decide what we
should only do during a pandemic
i haven't found very many places if any
that couldn't be easily explained like
postal regulations and other things
where the states that made changes and
roll back their
pandemic outreach
don't have more opportunities to vote
now than they had in 2018
the last election before they should
have done extraordinary things
actually one lesson we probably taught
state legislators here
is don't do anything to try to meet a
immediate moment
because if you try to undo it any of it
when that moment's passed
you'll get on what uh senator langford
described as the bad list
he also did a pretty good job explaining
that a lot of states that weren't on the
bad list
don't have nearly the opportunities to
vote that the states that are on the bad
list
you know one of the things i was elected
official for about 20 years including
the secretary of state for a good part
of that
and i always thought that the diversity
of the system was one of the strengths
of the system
i thought as president obama did in 2016
that the diversity of the system made it
really hard for outsiders or insiders
to figure out how they could rig a
national election
i still think that
this bill undermines
really
a lot of state voter laws that are
pretty popular with voters and we've
seen that expressed even in recent
elections in like new york city
prohibiting voter identification
for mail ballots would be one of the
things that you wouldn't
want to do if you wanted to have mail-in
ballots you'd want to be sure where
those came from and frankly
you'd want to have an objective standard
like your voter id number
or some other number that was uniquely
yours
than a subjective standard
like how you signed your name when you
were 18 as opposed to how you're signing
your name when you're 68.
that was one of the changes by the way
in the georgia law which should have
helped more people
than not
this bill retains senate bill one's
mandate on ballot drop boxes
federalizes rules for redistricting
i think it chills free speech
requires felon voting
now why would anybody want to be against
any of those things there are reasons
frankly to be against all of those
things but states make that decision
for themselves and in some states it may
work very well
and others it might not
of the top sweeping election
administration changes
uh in this bill
the s-1 policies in this bill disrupt
state
efforts to maintain accurate voter rolls
now accurate voter rolls were seen as
one of the great progressive moves
forward so
you'd have some sense that the people
who voted on election day
were actually people who were supposed
to vote and also important to vote in
that district
if you just vote anywhere
and your legislative district where you
should have bought was decided by four
or five votes and you were one of those
four or five suddenly
that's a big disservice to everybody
else
the bill would spend federal money to
campaign send federal money to campaign
coffers at the rate of six federal
dollars
for every dollar raised
it even goes so far as to add a second
public financing program
that would give people 25 dollars in
federal funds
to contribute to house candidates now
this six to one match is only for house
candidates
that may not be what the final bill
would say if we pass this bill but it's
only for house candidates now
and of course this federal money would
be eligible to be massed by six to one
other federal dollars
that's a pretty good deal you give
somebody 25 federal dollars and it could
be matched with
six to one other federal dollars
this bill sets up a framework that
would result in i think every
congressional district map
likely to be drawn by federal courts how
many maps have we seen this time
that were drawn by new improvements that
the states made that didn't turn out to
be one any better than the old maps and
two wound up being drawn by judges
the
john lewis voting right act
a friend of mine i served with him i
traveled with him i laughed with him i
liked him a lot i admired him a lot
this the the voting right act vote
voting rights act
was 12 pages
when it was introduced in 1965.
the john lewis voting right provisions
here
which have a great name but they're 120
pages
i voted to extend the voting rights act
and i'd do it again
and i'd be proud to do it if it was
named for
john lewis
but
735 pages
saying that if we don't vote for that
735 pages somehow we're opposed
to the voting rights act
or opposed to the heroism of john lewis
i i don't think so
since
it doesn't have the support to cast to
pass under the
current senate rules
the next thing we'll do is attempt to
really gut the legislative filibuster to
force it through
my republican colleagues have spoken at
length about the consequences of doing
that as has senator manchin and senator
cinema just the other day
the justification
rests on really a narrow basis that
somehow
the protection of the minority no longer
matters
the danger of overturning
200 years of
election administration by the state
i'm going to resist
doing any of the quotes this late in the
day that you've heard over and over
again of our democrat friends
who just a couple of years ago were
saying or hand
less than a handful of years ago
how critically important it was that
those rules
never be changed you know if democrats
eliminate the
60 vote rule for election legislation
uh there'll soon be no filibuster left
today it would be the carve out for
the election administration
uh three or four weeks ago it was a
carve out for um
for the debt raising the debt limit
the next carve out would be for whatever
seems to be important that day
the carve out won't work
i don't think really anybody here
believes that any longer this would be
the first step
in just eliminating an important
distinction
that makes the senate a place where we
have to think about what we do
it
eliminates some of the chaos that occurs
when
when you have a party change in the past
two decades
a single party has controlled both
chambers of the congress and the
presidency four times
alternating between democrats and
republicans
the senate is what has kept the country
from wildly going from one direction
back in the other
we don't want to lose that the
disaster for our citizens the disaster
for our economy of not having that
sense of having to think about this just
a little bit
before you head in another direction is
what the senate is all about i certainly
hope my colleagues
today will
not pass this federal takeover
of election laws
and will also resist the temptation
to change the rules of the senate
and i yield the floor
[Music]
madam vice president the senator from
minnesota
i rise today after hearing uh from my
friend senator blunt
i remember
on january 6 as all of you do that day
when he and i and vice president pence
and two young women with the mahogany
box filled with the last of the ballots
up to wyoming took that long walk
that long walk through the shattered
glass the spray-painted statues
and we did our jobs
and i will be forever grateful of what
he did at night on what so many people
in this chamber did
but for me
it didn't end that night
because sadly
what wasn't accomplished by the people
that rifled through
these deaths and got up on that dice
madam vice president
what wasn't accomplished with bear spray
what wasn't accomplished with the
bayonets and i still remember the blood
on the officer's faces sadly
has continued on
continued on
the votes
that we took that night were important
but the votes that the people of this
country take in every election are just
as important and that's why when you
look at the freedom to vote the john r
lewis act you have to understand what it
is grounded in
and that is our belief in our democracy
i want to thank every single member of
the democratic caucus that have worked
so hard to agree on this bill and i will
say the voting rights group the rules
committee
and i do differ
from senator blunt on this we spent a
lot of time making changes to that bill
over the year we have made many changes
and
response to concerns from secretaries of
state and local election officials all
across this country and i also thank you
and the president for your leadership
since this country's founding when brave
patriots rose up and ultimately
established a country in the name of we
the people america has been a shining
beacon for the world a touchdown for
democracy we travel the world as
senators as senator shaheen and portman
and i and several of our democratic and
republican colleagues did just this
weekend when we went to decry dictators
and bullies who attempt to undermine
democracies as vladimir putin is doing
in ukraine we were proud on that trip to
wear lapel pins with ukrainian flag on
one side and the united states flag on
the other we are proud of our democracy
and that democracy is fundamentally
based on the freedom to vote
over the years we've made improvements
to address wrongs that kept too many
americans from joining in the rights on
which our nation was founded but
generation after generation americans
have believed that truly
in our country's founding promise that
they've fought for it they've died for
it
we are here today against that backdrop
of history at a time when our democracy
is facing a new wave of threats a flood
that has surged up since the 2020
elections
when more americans cast a ballot than
ever before as a pandemic raged and it
is up to us to turn back that tide and
to preserve the right that lies at the
bedrock of our system of government and
again i disagree with senator blunt
about what has been going on
i look at the law that was passed in
montana that senator tester described
that was set in place for 15 years for
same-day registration in the state of
montana 15 years in the last election 8
000 people took advantage of it on
election day either newly registering to
vote or changing their address because
they moved
just taken away from them with what one
court described for another law years
ago in north carolina surgical precision
or you look at what our friend senator
ossoff and senator warnock describe of
what has happened in georgia 70 000
people
registered during that last weeks of the
election in the runoff period 70 000
people in the last election that has
been stripped away
passed into law that that cannot happen
again
the founding fathers knew that our
democracy would face obstacles a lot of
people have been quoting them
i'll quote this one samuel adams he said
this the liberties of our country are
worth defending at all hazards and it is
our duty to defend them against all
attacks
when you have over 9 000 threats against
members of congress in just last year
double triple what we've seen before
i don't see that walk we took that
really important walk
that that all ended that day when you
have local election officials across
this country being threatened the names
of their kids and their homes put out on
the internet like the republican local
election official in senator casey's
home state of pennsylvania his house his
kids with a threat that said tell the
truth or your three kids will be fatally
shot
it's on all of us to uphold and protect
this democracy
the freedom to vote john r lewis act
meets the challenges before us by
establishing basic federal standards for
our election restoring and strengthening
the voting rights act countering the
power of secret money in our politics
and taking on new threats to our
elections to ensure that every vote is
properly counted
and again let me read from the
constitution from article one section
four
that clause empowers congress to make or
alter rules for federal elections at any
time
at any time as senator kaine noted
that's the only time at any time is used
in the constitution
at any time
the word filibuster isn't in this
document
the word cloture isn't in this document
but
it was anticipated that congress could
and should be involved in federal
elections when necessary what brought us
to the point today
we're here in the midst of a concerted
effort to stop people from exercising
the most fundamental right in our
democracy
because as reverend warnock has put so
well
some people don't want some people to
vote we're here
because
the people of this country know what's
going on i'm talking about a veteran in
georgia who didn't have to stand in line
to serve his country
but he had to stood i met him myself he
had to stand in line hours and hours and
hours in the hot sun just to cast a
ballot we're here because those voters
in wisconsin who stood in the rain in
homemade mass and garbage bags in the
beginning of a pandemic just to exercise
their right to vote we're here because
of a voter in a wheelchair in texas who
traveled three hours on four buses just
to vote a woman in montana who had open
heart surgery uncertain about how to
return her mail ballot
a former election official from a rural
county was ousted by republicans in the
georgia legislature after a decade of
service
and a 92 year old woman who was purged
from the rolls after voting in every
election for decades since 1968.
we're here because after record number
of voters voted to make their voices
heard
there are people sadly that are working
in every state capital to make sure it
never happens again
and i note that for every one of these
laws that have passed
in 19 different states it has been with
a simple majority
state by state by state
a simple majority
and then as was noted by several of my
colleagues after this chamber has
established over 160 carve outs 160
processes in law to allow for a final
vote without 160 vote threshold whether
it's for the debt ceiling whether it's
for the bush tax cuts whether it's for
the trump tax cuts whether it is for
justice amy coney parrot 51 votes
now we hear at this very moment
that we must embrace this archaic rule
that is not in the constitution and did
not exist when the senate was founded
and we're not even talking about getting
rid of this rule we're simply talking
about restoring the senate to what it
once was so we can have debates and we
can actually vote on bills when those
debates have concluded and when the
speeches are exhausted
we're here because we took an oath to
defend the constitution as we did that
night on january 6th we're here because
we know that the eyes of the world are
on us watching to see if america will
stand up and take on the challenges of
our time
to paraphrase dr king whose legacy has
been honored many many times today
while there may be finite disappointment
in this country for so many people
every day
we must never lose infinite hope
we're not losing it
that my friends is why
we on the democratic side of the aisle
are supporting this bill with history's
eyes on us and with so much at stake we
must and we will fight on
thank you i yield the floor
madam vice president majority leader
madam vice president
what kind of democracy
shall endure here in the united states
long after our times in this chamber
come to an end
shall american democracy in the 21st
century be called a true heir to our
framers vision
a nation where the people choose their
own leaders
forge their own destiny
and add to the great legacies of those
who expanded the franchise before us
or shall we see america democrat
american democracy backslide in our time
grow feeble
in the jaws of its adversaries and
ultimately succumb
to the cancer
of voter suppression
the answer in a large sense
could depend on how we move forward this
evening as we have clearly laid out over
the past two days
laws passed in legislatures throughout
the country do nothing less
than to discourage and prevent certain
kinds of americans
black and brown americans young
americans elderly americans low-income
americans
from participating in the democratic
process
my colleagues
my colleagues
we can begin to put a stop to these
attacks tonight
by voting to proceed to the final
passage
of the freedom to vote act
and the john lewis voting rights
advancement act
these are good bills
these are effective bills
and they should be passed by this
chamber
as soon as possible
and if cloture is not invoked
we must change the rules of the senate
so we can pass these bills
into law
as we cast our votes i urge every one of
us democrat and republican
not to discount our place in history
the story of american democracy
is full of contradictions
and halting progress
at the time of our constitution's
ratification
you had to be in many states a white
male protestant landowner to vote
but ever since the early days of this
grand republic
americans launched mighty movements
fought a bloody civil war
and yes
passed federal election laws
to expand the franchise until there were
no more boundaries
today's vote is the next step
in that long march
are we going to let our democracy
backslide into in the 21st century
are we going to be dragged back into the
abyss
of voter suppression
i urge every one of my colleagues
left right and middle
for the sake of our democracy
unite
take a stand today
to every member of this body who
treasures our precious experiment in
self-rule
to every member horrified
by the muck of voter suppression
and to everyone
who believes this chamber
is still capable
of defending democracy in its hour of
great need
i urge
a yes vote
heal the floor
the clerk will report the motion to
invoke cloture
cloture motion
we the undersigned senators in
accordance with the provisions of rule
22 of the standing rules of the senate
to hereby move to bring to a close the
debate on the motion to concur
in the house amendment to the senate
amendment to h.r
5746 and act to amend title 51
united states code to extend the
authority of the national aeronautics
and space administration to enter into
leases of non-excess property of the
administration signed by 17 senators
by unanimous consent the mandatory
quorum call has been waived the question
is is it the sense of the senate that
debate on the motion to concur in the
house amendment to the senate amendment
to h.r
5746
and act to amend title 51 united states
code to extend the authority of the
national aeronautics and space
administration to enter into leases of
non-excess property of the
administration shall be brought to a
close
the yeas and nays are mandatory under
the rule the clerk will call the role ms
baldwin
mr barrasso
mr bennett
mrs
blackburn mr blumenthal
mr blunt
mr booker
mr boseman
mr brawn
mr brown
mr burr
miss cantwell
mrs capito
mr cardin
mr carper
mr casey
mr cassidy
ms collins
mr coons
mr
cornyn miss cortez masto
mr cotton
mr kramer
mr crapo
mr cruz
mr daines
miss duckworth
mr durbin
ms ernst
mrs feinstein
mrs fisher
mrs gillibrand
mr graham
mr grassley
mr hagerty
miss hassan
mr hawley
mr heinrich
mr hickenlooper
miss hirono
mr hoeven
mrs hyde smith
mr inhofe
mr johnson
mr kane
mr kelly
mr kennedy
mr king
miss klobuchar
mr
lankford mr leahy
mr lee
mr lujan
miss lomas
mr mansion
mr markey
mr marshall
mr mcconnell
mr menendez
mr merkley
mr moran
ms murkowski
mr murphy
mrs murray
mr assaf
mr padilla
mr paul
mr peters
mr portman
mr reed
mr rish
mr romney
ms rosen
mr rounds
mr rubio
mr sanders
mr sass
mr schatz
mr schumer
mr scott of florida
mr scott of south carolina
mrs shaheen
mr shelby
miss cinema
miss smith
miss stavenell
mr
sullivan mr tester
mr thune
mr tillis
mr toomey
mr tuberville
mr van hollen
mr warner
mr warnock
miss warren
mr whitehouse
mr wicker
mr wyden
mr young
[Music]
yeah mr paul
miss collins
mr hoeven
mr kramer
mr carper
senators voting in the affirmative
baldwin
bennett
blumenthal
booker
brown
cantwell
cardin
carper
casey
coons
cortez masto
duckworth
durbin
feinstein
gillibrand
hassan heinrich
hickenlooper
hirono
kane
kelly
king
klobuchar
leahy
lujan
mansion
menendez
merkley
murphy
murray
assaf padilla
peters
reed
rosen
sanders
shots
schumer
shaheen
cinema
smith
stabenow
tester
van hollen
warner
warnock
warren
whitehouse and wyden
senators voting in the negative
barrasso
blackburn
blunt
braun
burr
collins cornyn
cotton
cramer
crapo
cruz
danes
ernst
fischer
graham
hagerty holly
hoeven heid smith inhofe
johnson
kennedy
lee
lummus
mcconnell
murkowski
paul
risch
romney rounds
rubio scott of florida scott of south
carolina
shelby
sullivan
thune
tillis tuberville and young
mr wicker no
mr sass
no
mr lankford
no mr moran
no
mr timmy
no
[Music]
hmm
mr grassley
no
[Music]
mr cassidy no
[Music]
mr portman
no
[Music]
so
great
hmm
this is capitao
[Music]
so
so
mr busman
no
mr marshall
no
[Music]
okay
so
okay
mr schumer
mr schumer
no
[Music]
all right
on this vote the a's are 49
the nays are 51. three-fifths of the
senators duly chosen and sworn not
having voted in the affirmative
the motion is not agreed to
madam president madam vice president
i enter a nation to reconsider the
failed cloture vote
the motion is entered
madam president
from connecticut
madam president asked that we have a
lawyer in the senate
madam president
madam vice president
as we
head towards the final
hour of debate
i want to just bring us back
about 20 feet to talk about the
stakes
that we
are laboring under tonight
i want to talk a little bit about the
big picture of why this matters i know
we've changed the rules
160 times in the history of the senate
but i will submit that it is still an
extraordinary
endeavor to ask our colleagues to change
the rules and traditions of this body
and so here's what i want to say
it is really important to remember
that democracy
this idea that every member of our
country every member of the community
gets an equal say in the rules that
govern us
it is
unnatural
why do i know this
because i want you to think of every
organization in your life
that matters
your workplace
it doesn't give equal votes to every
employee as to the direction of the
company
think about your favorite sports team
there's not a vote from all the players
about the lineups
or the strategy of the team
the sunday sermon at your church isn't
chosen by an online
you